do you you really believe five hundred  to two thousand dollars is uh that that  Delta that people might may or may not  be able to afford is is a strong  justification for killing 850 000 human  beings every year so again saying the  term killing 800 000 human beings no  that that is using manipulative and  emotional languages you said that the  fetus is a human being that's that  wasn't my language that's your language  okay but killing a human being is not  the same as aborting a fetus but you can  use the manipulative and emotional  language if you'd like I'm only using  your language because you said that the  it's alive and it's a human being and so  what do you call it when you end a life  this is killing that's just the precise  way to describe it and what do you call  a human being as a human being so I said  you're killing a human being that's your  language if that's how you'd like to  describe it that's fine that's how you  described it